this is a Fox News Alert we have just
learned that Senator Rand Paul has
tested positive for the corona virus the
official confirmation came in a series
of tweets just a few minutes ago and I
want to read them to you in full they
read Senator Rand Paul has tested
positive for kovat 19 he is feeling fine
and he is in quarantine he is
asymptomatic and was tested out of an
abundance of caution due to his
extensive travel and events he was not
aware of any direct contact with any
infected person he expects to be back in
the Senate after his quarantine period
ends and will continue to work for the
people of Kentucky at this difficult
time ten days ago our DC office began
operating remotely hence virtually no
staff has had contact with Senator Rand
Paul so that's certainly some good news
there but Leland Senator Rand Paul
becoming just the latest member of
Congress to test positive for the corona
virus and we knew that this was
certainly a possibility when you have
this many members of Congress traveling
and flying from all parts of the country
here to Capitol Hill it brings up a
couple of important issues number one
voting because they have to vote in
person by law on things and you've got
this huge couple trillion dollar
spending bill coming up there's
questions about what the house is gonna
do would they pass it by unanimous
consent so they don't all have to fly
back from their districts what happens
if it's a close vote what are the
constitutional rules as it relates to
voting from some distance away the other
thing on a personal level you think
about Rand Paul he's a physician
physician himself if there's anybody who
would know as your father would and
other Doc's that we know about the risks
of the corona virus and how to be
careful in your everyday life not to get
it it would be him so it does show you
just how contagious this virus can be we
know Cory Gardner is in quarantine as
well the senator from Colorado's so is
this mushrooms out as we think about
just how different the week looked a
week ago and what we were talking about
last Sunday versus today just
extrapolate that out till 7 days from
now in America will once again look very
different it just shows you anybody can
get the corona virus and if you think it
might be easy
to allow members of Congress to vote
remotely just think of what happened
during the Iowa caucus these things are
not easy to do they're very
technologically difficult and while
they're not you know it's kind of like
comparing apples and oranges but it is
anytime you try to do something digital
that that is that is that complex it's
tough so not gonna be ready in time you
know that there are contingency plans
out there whether or not they get put
into use or not we'll wait and see as
the negotiations on Capitol Hill
continue in that bill was the spending
bill is something that Rand Paul
certainly had a number of thoughts about